a caravan of more than 2700 Hondurans
hoping to get to the US it's one of
several that have set out from Honduras
since 2018 carrying many seeking to
escape violence and extreme poverty
comen Ramirez a coffee grower is
travelling with his younger son he says
they've no choice and I have big debts
in Honduras that I just can't pay
because your work doesn't pay enough to
support even yourself this woman says
her nephews were killed over Christmas
and she's left so they can't get her son
to she's too scared to let us film her
face losing a son would hurt me more
than anything else we've already made
the decision even if they don't let us
pass we can't go back for now at the
Casa del Migrante a shelter in Guatemala
City they're safe and have medical care
food and a place to sleep even if it is
only under the tarpaulin that father
Merrill the center director is setting
up he expected more than a thousand I
asked how they were going to fit they
have to what else are we going to do we
have to work miracles here that's the
situation we're in those in the caravan
we'll need more miracles heading north
Mexico under pressure from US President
Donald Trump has said it won't let them
through those who do manage to get to
the US border find disappointment right
at the moment that this caravan of
Hondurans are trying to get through
Guatemala and eventually to the United
States plane loads of their countrymen
are actually being sent back we'd
already got there and asked for asylum
to here Guatemala and that tells you how
little their chances are of actually
being accepted for asylum at the end of
this journey
Mouser knows that he's one of those
who've gone on past caravans without
success ask him why he's trying again we
have nothing to lose because in Honduras
we have nothing you understand our lives
are at risk in Honduras
as we leave the shelter people are
queuing to get in they know their
journey is only gonna get harder but
they're still going on John Holman al
Jazeera Guatemala City